a bus stop shooting left a man dead in
the east valley and this afternoon that
gunman is still on the run we brought
you this is breaking news of that
investigation near nellis and boulder
highway earlier this morning hector
mejia explains what may have led to the
violence
the victim was in his 30's and he was at
this bus stop when police believe
someone shot him during some sort of
argument late at night along boulder
highway just south of nellis metro
police lieutenant jason johansen says it
was reported just before three thursday
morning while details are limited they
believe the victim was sitting at the
bus stop when an encounter with another
man took a deadly turn while he was
there he became involved in some type of
altercation with another male
during which he was shot the wounded
victim ran northbound toward sam's town
hotel and gambling hall seeking help
victim collapsed across the street to
the north of me
and he did but the actual incident took
place right here at the bus stop he was
rushed to sunrise hospital but did not
survive the investigation kept a couple
of lanes of boulder highway closed for a
few hours they believe the suspect
disappeared southbound many who used
this bus stop were left stunned as they
watched officers search for clues we
secure the whole area usually a crime
scene that's larger than where the
actual incident happened just in case
there's any evidence if you know
anything that could help police solve
this murder you can remain anonymous by
calling crime stoppers reporting in the
east valley hector mejia live local now